hello and welcome to this video let's go
and play just one guitar one can I do
here they all play the London system
nowadays I can they can try it have once
let's see what we get there are some
some sharp lines with Queen B 6 for
example I think okay not here so I guess
we just develop him yeah and I sometimes
wonder if this is an option I mean okay
I've got the night on the tube already
but it's not ideal rather have it on c3
but I always felt like maybe white has a
little something there on the CFR okay
that hanging of unprotected bishop 23 is
something that I have to keep in mind
but Ike and nothing happens like if 5
can be a move and I cannot take twice as
g3 hangs but this has become obsolete at
that point mmm maybe ok black black
maybe you can just double on the C file
that's possible now probably you can it
is a fairly solid set up there what
black chose I play like that myself but
usually they take with the e porn and
always wonder if maybe taking with the
sea point is there is an alternative
that can be worth considering
okay let's see see file probably nothing
happens here well I also thought about
efore maybe a 45 okay let's see what he
does I mean sometimes we we get help
clear by opponents play not like I mean
not expecting them to blunder as just
that sometimes you get a clearer idea
what to do if you know what your
opponent is up to and so I would
probably just double on on the C file
yes black a group c 7 but it seems to be
a little bit unsure what to do okay
right cannot be bad yeah i got my w hike
like this it's not nothing special
the only other idea would be e for like
push 44 okay hmm interesting not sure
why you need to go back to d8 but soon
okay in black is so solid that he can do
that okay yeah I don't think so okay
here Scott term is got Quincy one lined
up and queen d 1 yes Bishop to a 6 well
that's really nothing at all okay I
think after I probably have to press
water out of stone iam it's the only way
to get to do something in this position
yeah the London system it's not really
the kind of opening way you expect
fireworks but this is really lame let's
see maybe I can gain a little bit of
space it would be for be five or
something along these lines maybe
hmm well I can take before and night see
for it could be a little something a
little something d D 596 is definitely a
slight edge show it does that
interesting because he now has to take
on these six I think okay maybe yes God
Bishop the sound that was a little bit
hey I Scott this move not okay still
interesting here what to do
tough you should be six maybe let's do
this maybe I can get in like might be
five and I am ok
Bishop c8 as a move here
alright let's try that now that's good
news I just have reported and just I
reported the cheetah the game are before
that was some very very weird game and I
reported my opponent for cheating oh wow
isn't that a fork or a skewer I don't
know and I got the points back that's
nice they will bend the guy and I get my
points back and I'm getting points here
because he just blundered into this is
weird night Bishop walking two nights
that's 22 to Windsor in like half a
minute anyway yeah but there was nothing
going on it was just a very Jewish
position black resigns yeah nothing
happens nothing happens really i think
maybe if maybe I have a little something
here like this this but I think b5
should save the day yeah I can do this
but I don't know it's very unlikely that
that I'm having anything here at night
extra looks a bit strained at which well
it shouldn't get lost that that it's not
happening but my yes problems moving is
pieces but it is equal that's equal as
it was basically the whole time still on
b5 is given by the given by stockfish
interesting this and this white has a
slight pool here it really is like that
a little bit a little bit of a pool with
this now in the part of the picture but
maybe here I can try a little bit I can
try a little bit it's quite remarkable
that there's still something I was
surprised that he played on d5 I was
expecting expecting this but d5 is also
a little bit a little bit of pressure
rats I mean it doesn't look like what
should we know anything but if anybody
why does doing it a little bit of a
little bit of a squeeze job here yeah
it's very equal ish as as I said I'm
very equal opening I think he played it
defended everything well yeah it's a
it's a little something but it shouldn't
be as much as as it was in the game on
the app has to take the ages is a weird
weird motif but two nights on the same
color complex cannot protect each other
it just doesn't happen and a full night
gets gets lost here funny okay well
thanks for watching